public cloud is an incredible resource
for developers today it brings the
ability to provision resources on demand
and only pay for what you use this leads
to greater developer efficiency while
bringing down overall costs but what
exactly makes up a public cloud today
we'll start with an analogy say you
wanted to bake a pie from scratch well
how come in and are you gonna make your
own flour you're gonna grow your own
fruits well in this society we've
generally accepted that for certain
ingredients you'll go to a supermarket a
public cloud is a supermarket of sorts
it has multiple vendors and multiple
solutions allowing you to pick and
choose the right tools and solutions for
your taste now to start my explanation
of public cloud I could start by talking
about things like infrastructure of the
service or maybe platforms or software
as a service more naturally known as
paths I as an SAS but instead I'm going
to focus on the overall control and
overhead for the different compute
solutions that are available in a public
cloud so as a box gets bigger here
there's more control but that comes with
more overhead now let's start with the
biggest box where we've got things like
bare metal
now with this you're gonna have the most
control but that also comes with a lot
of overhead to actually maintain those
instances let's take it a step higher
here we've got things like V PC and
VMware so with these solutions you're
gonna have a little less overhead
because there's automation that allows
you to spin up the actual machines going
a step higher we've got solutions like
kubernetes and open shift container
platform these will allow you to get
kind of higher abstraction over the
actual worker nodes the machines that
power your actual cluster are basically
going to be managed by the platform and
you can focus on writing
containers and going up higher on the
list we get to things like Cloud Foundry
as well as functions which are gonna
allow you to focus as a developer
entirely on the code and let the
platform take care of things like
networking and scaling and that kind of
thing so we've got our set of
capabilities for compute but that's not
the only thing in a public cloud you're
going to have integrations and services
that allow you to start spinning up
capabilities that you need so today
let's go over a sample application
architecture for which we're going to
use the public cloud now let's say to
start we have something like a legacy
application that relies on VMs or
bare-metal capabilities so we'll say
over here that we've got VPC and/or
bare-metal now on top of this we're
gonna spin up some containers some
machines rather now in those machines
let's say we have our legacy back-end
application so we'll scale it out onto
three different machines so there we go
we've got our back-end pieces now that
covers our back-end compute of our
sample application now let's say for our
front-end application we're taking a
model where we have a front end and a
back end for front-end which are based
on containers so here it's a little bit
of a different model the worker nodes
are going to be managed for us by the
kubernetes or OpenShift layer so here
we'll have the kubernetes and our
OpenShift layer now on top of this we
can start deploying our containers so
let's say like we mentioned we have that
front-end as well as a back-end for that
front-end application and for each of
those we want to scale those out which
kubernetes or openshift can handle for
us
there we go so these are the basics of
our application architecture we've got
some back-end stuff we've got some
front-end stuff and all of that is kind
of running on some of our compute
solutions let's actually start taking
advantage of some of the cloud
integrations that are possible to build
out some of the other requirements we
have here first things first
storage so our front-end application
let's say we need something like I don't
know a sequel database to actually store
things like customer login data so our
applications here are gonna use say a
sequel datastore there we go now for our
back-end application let's say we need
something different not a standard
sequel store but something like cloud
object storage so here we'll sketch out
a cloud object store instance which is
going to be using which our back-end
application will be using so we've
talked about storage next let's talk
about DevOps and toolchain capabilities
which will also take advantage of our
public cloud for now our code is
probably split into two different
repositories for this particular
application that we've got here or
kubernetes app we'll say we've got a set
of code for the actual containers and
applications and a separate set of code
for the actual infrastructure because we
want to manage our infrastructure as
code as well now for this we want to
take advantage of some tool chain
capabilities so for our app we'll take
advantage of a tool chain which will
deploy our containers now for our
infrastructure I'm going to take
advantage of a similar tool chain but in
this case we want to use terraform which
is an open source way of managing your
infrastructure is code to actually
manage the infrastructure so in this
case this will manage for spinning up
the worker nodes as well as the
kubernetes layer
so there we go we've got we've talked
about so far storage as well as DevOps
from our cloud next let's talk about you
know having a central maybe logging or
monitoring solution for our tools so
we've got our back-end application here
as well as our front-end application and
for both of those we want to stream to a
central logging store so let's say I've
got a logging service that I've created
here and that's going to be our central
source of logs for both our application
running on kubernetes as well as our
back-end application running within
VMware or bare-metal or V PC so there we
go we've talked about central logging
now now the next service that I want to
take advantage of is things thinking
about things like networking and
security so in this in this sample
architecture for our back-end piece
let's say we've got really private data
we want to make sure that access to that
back-end piece only happens over private
endpoints and for our front-end piece we
don't care quite as much we can access
over the public endpoint so making kind
of like a bi section here we'll say that
this is entirely private private
endpoints only and this side we can
access our data over public endpoints
now this doesn't mean our data is
insecure
we can still use something that allows
us to bring our own keys to secure our
data with our own kind of certs and keys
so both of these environments are going
to be completely secured but by making
this bisection how does our front-end
app now start talking to some of those
back-end capabilities that we've got so
again we can tap into our cloud and take
advantage of something like a VPN
gateway so here we go we'll set up a
gateway so that our front-end and
back-end can start talking to one
another now this is just scratching the
surface of the capabilities that are
available in a public cloud we haven't
even begun just talk about some of the
artificial intelligence machine learning
data analytics and insights and so many
other services that are available in a
generic public cloud thanks for watching
this overview of public cloud if you
have any questions please drop us a line
below if you want to see more videos
like this in the future please like and
subscribe and don't forget you can
always get started on the cloud had no
cost by signing up for a free IP em
cloud account